pourquoi le marquis s'attacherait t-il à
cette fille alors qu'ils ne s'attachent
à aucune autre parce que le martineau
résiste pas ceux qui lui résistent
madame brad et moi services lesquels il
est complet sur moi je veux la voir
et les l'état de votre coeur il faut que
cette filière comme au ps se marquer ses
devoirs berg grands comédiens français
plus de soixante long-métrages en
carrière mais c'est pas tout les réalise
scénarise il anime à la radio il écrit
des pièces de théâtre les met en scène
et c'est surtout un amoureux de la
langue française avec lui les mots
deviennent véritablement de symphonies
lutte au québec pour présenter ce
dimanche le film mademoiselle de
jonquière au festival cinémania qui se
déroule en ce moment et qui met en
valeur le cinéma le cinéma de langue
française
bah il nous fait le plaisir de s'arrêter
dans nos studios edouard baer bonsoir
aujourd'hui je dis tout de suite que
vous allez faire vos lumières dans la
nuit oui oui on en direct dimanche soir
vont être hébergés décollage du berger
par cette grande maison
oui alors vous cherchez des bonnes
adresses et vous allez avoir plein
d'invités autour de vous alors ça c'est
l'animateur de radio vous êtes à
montréal dans ce festival cinémania qui
met en valeur le cinéma dans le français
je veux d'abord parler de ceux de sète
de cet événement dont on pourra
peut-être pas assez mais pourquoi c'est
important de promouvoir le cinéma
français le cinéma de langue française
de cinéma de la francophonie moi je suis
comme beaucoup de gens je suis très
attaché à ça et je crois comme c'est un
peu un lieu commun de dire moi mon pays
c'est mal en quoi c'est bon je suis plus
que géographique je me suis beaucoup
plus proche d'un habitant de montréal
que que d'européens d'autres langues
doit donc cesser ce bouleversant de
savoir si ce n'est des gens parlent pas
français il parle leur langue c'est pas
une langue c'est pas coloniale c'est une
enquête et quand on voyage qu'on voit
que les gens leur façon par les français
de le vide devant leurs auteurs d'avoir
leur cinéma tout à coup ça nous
enrichissent et des échanges c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir une dent en
commun ah oui qu'est la majorité -
chouchou j'aime bien les choses qui sont
pas majeurs la mairie chose de nichane
âgées au québec
non mais c'est une solidarité sur iphone
c'est tellement grande que c'est une
identité francophone c'est une c'est un
petit clin d'oeil entre soit vous avez
déjà déjà déjà déclaré que votre seule
maîtresse
vous savez mais ça n'a pas été une
connerie de dire que langue française
vous l'aimé passionnément vous avez
grandi dans un milieu qui favorise l
éducation d'instruction la lecture très
jeune talent au théâtre vous avez à des
rives des cours de théâtre et dans ce
film on y viennent mademoiselle
dejonckheere est ce que c'est la langue
française tels que vous l'aimez le plus
parce que cette langue c'est la langue
vraiment de molière on est au xviiie
siècle avec des costumes
c'est de toute beauté c'est fluide c'est
beau c'est chez un milieu c'est une
époque où tout à coup les gens l'ont le
goût du mot précis ce qui est
merveilleux dans les mots c'est ça c'est
la richesse du vocabulaire promet pour
exprimer une chose et ça grandit plus en
animaux puis ça veut dire qu'on a des
nuances de penser des nuances de
sentiments et donc ses merveilleuses
tout à coup ça nous ça grandit l'être
humain contrairement si on se résume à
500 mo ça va être notre pensée nos
sentiments se résume aussi mais si tout
à coup on s'aperçoit là je me dis anne
marie est ce qu elle est attentive elle
est est ce que est ce qu'elle est
guetteuses est ce qu'elle est ennuyé il
ya une palette extraordinaire qui monte
et ces gens là dans mademoiselle de
jonquière sont des personnages et ils
consacrent leur vie à ça a commenté leur
vie amoureuse il travaille pas beaucoup
et des aristos c'est des gens qui sont
des gens qui travaillent pour eux y sont
ils s'écrivent isli commente y voit là
il rêve mais c'était une des choses que
vous en tirez dans le 3g et wi mais
c'est aussi une histoire merveilleuse
c'est une histoire d'amour incroyable
c'est des personnages qui se révèlent
eux et non mais je trouve mon bois mon
personnage est au clavecin et qui défend
beaucoup mieux mais non mais c'est très
extraordinaire c'est des gens qui sont
très libres d'esprit et qui invente le
requin vente leur vie tient d'abord une
histoire d'amour où il ya un espèce de
un mélange de passion
de séduction de mensonges de vengeance
de cruauté c'est ça les recettes de
l'amour
ah bah oui mais parce que quand ils
fouillent sinon ça serait plaint on
s'ennuierait beaucoup sinon je me fait
comme roméo juliette veut susciter à 20
ans un enfant après forcément on est là
on a 12 ans et pille on est toujours
déçu c'est les montagnes russes et il
faut accepter les descentes si on veut
voir les montées il faut accepter les
dessins à l'appui
mais qu'est ce qui vous a séduit dans ce
projet là en particulier non mais ses
charges et diderot l'histoire de madame
de la padres et diderot c'est un zeste
de jean-pierre c'est moi je trouve
extraordinaire de jouer un personnage
qui qui se désagrège complètement qui a
pas prévu c'est quelqu'un qui se prend
pour casanova pour qui l'amour est un
jeu l'amour est un plaisir
c'est pas un don juan c'est un
manipulateur c'est un jouisseur un peu
et qui croit qu'il va être plus fort que
ça et puis d'un coup il lui arrive qu'il
doit pas arriver c'est de tomber
amoureux et quand on dit bien tombé
amoureux donc c'est à dire tout à coup
c'est quelqu'un qui s'aperçoit qu'il
peut qu'il ne peut plus vivre c'est
formidable d'avoir quelqu'un qui se
liquéfie complètement parce que parce
qu'il n'a pas ce qu'il veut et pour vous
qui avez joué dans plus de 60 films
parce que c'est un jeu un body fodic le
petit peu là soit 60 de marée du sens et
c'est bien mais des boîtes boli mais
c'est votre bilan de carrière des séries
télé oui alors 38 millions d'entrées
naveau film un mois hier c'était la
révélation de l'année la molière oui
c'était pour une question et cravate
avec charles berling de fabrice argelas
donc avec beaucoup de fidélité ça dans
le choix de vos personnages dansent wade
des rôles que vous voulez jouer mais où
william et on essaie de le premier choix
c'est le metteur en scène aussi parce
que manuel mouret c'est quelqu'un de
deux très inspirant c'est un univers
très singulier qui est obsédé par le pas
ne pas la relation amoureuse par les
sentiments par tous que quand on dit de
percer dans les contes pour enfants
s'amusent toujours pas ils se marièrent
et eurent beaucoup d'enfants mais au
fait c'est là que la vie commence et
c'est là que ça commence à être
intéressant car je sais comment ça c'est
quand on sait quand on est amoureux
quand on a l'air heureux là ça commence
le problème quand on plante cette
histoire dans le décor de mouret
justement c'est aussi une oeuvre d'art
le paysage le choix des teintes août les
délais
le jeu des lumières où vous attendez
vous vous êtes un traître et un peuple
un très lent vous êtes tous les deux
puis vous marchez dans la forêt mais
sponsors et après c'est une forêt c'est
très beau c'est très verdoyant et le
plus grand costumier de cinéma aussi
pierre jean larroque
c'est d'une précision c'est vraiment le
grand style français c'est c'est ce sont
ses châteaux ses ce début du xviiie là
l'image oui ça ressemble aussi à des
choses plus classiques a débouché à des
fragonard des choses comme ça c'est un
peu le grand siècle français c'est vrai
monsieur chatouille à ces jardins les
fameux jardins à la française qui sont
magnifiques traditionnels c'est un film
que sélectionné pré sélectionné pour les
oscars ce que ça sera important pour
vous de représenter la france aux oscars
moi ce que moi le ce qui me touche le
plus c'est que les gens rient au cinéma
je dire aujourd'hui mais c'est ça que
c'est ça que je trouve extraordinaire
c'est comme un film sur la langue une
langue très at il très châtié très très
belle très près ce que littéraire mais
les émotions pas sont si fortes que tout
à coup les gens soient les devoirs ça
sont allés voir et et en france est un
c'est un grand succès moi ça me ça
m'émeut qu'aujourd'hui en 2018 ya encore
eu des motards sur 1000 personnes qui la
france qui va voir ça et qu'ils en
soient bouleversés sachons c'est est ce
que c'est un film parce qu'on parle
d'amour de pureté de vengeance en
racontera pas d'histoire c'est un film
féminin et féministe aussi mais payet il
a plusieurs clés ce film c'est aussi
pour ça moi j'aime pas les filles qui
apporte la réponse d'un film il ya
beaucoup de questions et il ya le point
de vue de cécile de france qui est
extraordinaire si et c'est un des
aspects du film c'est la vengeance d'une
femme d'une femme trahie d'une femme
déçue qui se sent victime la ville
séducteur et puis il ya une autre il ya
une autre histoire aussi qu'ils essaient
de cet homme qui décide de de réinventer
sa vie il découvrait un prise des coûts
et puis là le courage c'est vrai libre
esprit et tout à coup il va vivre une
vie que personne n'attendait
ce que c'est une époque où il ya
énormément de rumeurs les ce qu'ils
appellent l'honneur les gens à cette
époque c'est beaucoup leur réputation
est ce personnage là il va aller plus
loin que ça parce que il est bien beau
personne parce que madame de la
pommeraie d'amendés 6
une âme juste ne tente pas de corriger
les hommes comment espérer une meilleure
société
on pourrait dire ça aujourd'hui en 2010
pour ce qu'il faut corriger les oeuvres
d'art et d'une écoute c'est le
personnage qui le mouves corriger nous
mène en mai donc je crois qu'en tout cas
c'est une époque évidemment les
abonnements mettre en question certains
comportements sociaux publics et dans la
vie professionnelle est ce que les
hommes appellent la séduction leurs
droits leurs droits séduire à plaire
équipe qui parfois devenu une sorte de
choses un peu de deux chasseurs et donc
oui on fasse ouvrit il ya sûrement des
choses qui doivent se mettre à niveau
mais incitant le personnage au format
question s'était excusé moi j'ai pas du
tout exprès si je suis maintenant je
sais bien à ces décalages c'est plus de
la bêtise la manipulation votre côté
comédien humain et tout mais au fond si
je cite cette cet extrait de bram de la
pommeraie c'est tout simplement pour
dire peut-être que ce film même si se
déroule en costume au xviiie siècle des
lumières inspiré de diderot c'est un
film aussi très très moderne
pourquoi il est moderne ce film je veux
travailler ford ont fait travailler très
fort l'âge et la fumée qui sort des
oreilles il ya des réponses et moi je
crois qu'il est moderne parce que c'est
parce qu'être déçu amoureusement parce
qu'être parce que parce que
se venger parce que voilà jusqu'où est
ce qu'on a le droit se venger s'estimer
victime parce qu'il n'y a rien de pire
que quand on croit qu'on est victimes on
s'autorise tout dans la vie les gens les
plus violents et les gens qui se
comportent le plus méchamment c'est des
gens qui s'estiment victimes
moi je suis pas du tout le personnel de
france devient très dur à cause de ça
appartement où elle décide que cet homme
l'a trahie elle s'autorise des choses
d'une dureté terrible 7 cette modernité
la dent dans le film elle elle est
peut-être la cour la raison de ce succès
aussi oui mais parce que c'est le
courage aussi d'une femme
à une époque où les femmes se la boucler
comme ça n'existe pas une femme qui se
rebellent contre ça c'est une femme qui
dit non c'est pas toujours les hommes
qui ont le beau rôle s'est passé c'est
pas les hommes qui sont des séducteurs
des libertins et c'est beau et ça donne
des rentrants voit enfin la métamorphose
de ses débuts sous rien à rien et
forcément oui mais la maman ils croient
qu'ils croient que l'amour est un jeu
que l'amour est juste un plaisir et
s'est passé c'est pas comme ça les gens
sont pas des marionnettes des gens sont
pas des jouets elle le lui rappelle et
après ça s'inscrit dans votre visage
dans le film là la douleur quand vous
attrapez assez merveilleux à jouer ça je
trop de bruit de plus avoir de vernis
social du tout oui c'est quand on y
arrive plus quoi ces passages où il ya
des matins tout à coup on croit qu'on
aime sa vie quand même son métier
connaît sa famille il ya un chagrin
amoureux puis tout à coup on s'aperçoit
que plus rien d'eux il ya quelqu'un qui
dit qu'il n'y arrive plus tout ça donc
on peut s'y reconnaît est ce que je peut
vous amener sur le terrain de votre
autre métier parce que vous en avez
plusieurs en même temps je sais pas si
vous savez qu'à 24 heures dans une
journée
mais vous êtes passé des matinales donc
à la radio nova en france de l'équité ça
vous venez de commencer une émission
lumière dans la nuit
donc je les vois qu'au début vous allez
faire cette émission en direct imaginent
demain pour les français 22 heures à
minuit sur france inter mais je veux
quand même rappeler à nos
téléspectateurs c'est parce que j'ai
fait l'émission il était dernièrement ya
une semaine donc on va écouter un court
extrait pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas de ce que ça donne quand
on vous écoute à la radio
dans ce pays nous sommes ici que mes
coups canada suivant francophones
anglophones aux problèmes de fédéralisme
sous les indépendances dans ce pays où
nous sommes ici où tout nous semble
d'une scandaleuse douceur la question la
question se pose quand ils auront
souffert ou être heureux faut-il avoir
subi les frimas les engelures dègla sur
les ongles qui tombe le grand bleu grand
froid les mains les pieds qu'on oublie
pour enfin profiter
faut-il qu'ils aient eu generali mais
pour que le commandant d'aidé puissent
exister alors tous les matins comme ça
vous à provisions alors je commence l
émission comme ça pas mais c'est j'étais
encore un peu dans le sommeil donc c'est
un peu de la conscience des lèvres il y
en a des plus ou moins raté mais là
j'étais inspiré parce que ça me touche
énormément de venir si moi j'étais
nourri
je regarde énormément de choses sur eux
et puis sur toutes les grandes années
des convainc dépend dentiste ici qu'on
soit ou non pour l'indépendance c'était
des moments vraiment bouleversant quand
même les années lévesque souhaite
et puis le et se fait même pas que le
québec et la france d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus près h ier c'est de cette fameuse
arrivée du général de gaulle on sait pas
approprié pour prendre soin de vous et
si bien jacques dunnigan néocolonialiste
non mais j'ai le bon côté regarder ça
sur internet ça me bouleverse sa vie
et puis et puis les choses qui vous
laisse le plus c'est le concert eux
charlebois vigneault félix leclerc sur
sur la place là et tout ça quand tu
chantes quand les hommes vivront d'amour
il y aura une misère c'est des moments
extraordinaires je sais pas ah oui ça
mais je peux pas vous dire ça me
bouleverse mais j'étais un peu lâche
comme beaucoup de français c'est à dire
je n'ai plus tôt l'été et je trouve que
c'est pas gentil avec avec les cousins
de pub de pas venir partager des moments
plus compliqués
voilà bah oui c'est ça c'est vigneault à
mon pays c'est l'hiver donc il faut
venir il faut me dire dans leur pays oui
et donc ça vous inspire
sur votre travail c'est de
l'improvisation pure il ya des je
prenais des notes et puis j'essaie
d'être dans un état un peu de en face et
les musiques qui peut voyager des
musiques et puis en les envoyant me
viennent des images m'ont parfois c'est
ce soir on sait maintenant comment ces
noms le soir ça marche pas j'ai essayé
de faire des impôts comme cet été raté
donc je fais autre chose ici
le chercher mais le soir c'est une
émission que je fais plutôt un mouvement
pas trader me balade dans des rues j ai
vu des gens ici j'aurais voulu le faire
mais techniquement c'était compliqué
donc si vous je crois que je suis
accueillie dans les studios ici et je
vais inviter des gens plus ou moins
connus des gens d'ici des gens de france
des gens que j'ai croisés dans les rues
mais cet exemple prouve j'en ai vu un
aussi sur le 4 avril 4 avril
oui donné le 2 novembre non mais c'est
pas il fait dans un état un peu
inconscient parce que je n'ai pas le
talent luchini de pouvoir c'est de
l'abandon en quoi c'est pas du contrôle
donc voilà c'est un peu c'est un truc un
peu comme c'est la démonstration de la
prouesse des mots afin que vous faites
la facilité peut-être avec laquelle vous
arrivez à jouer avec les bassins s'il ya
des petits états des motions s'est
confessée musique m'émeuvent la
situation d'être l' appui à leur
apprennent parfois les mots et les maux
viennent et parfois ça ouais enfin c'est
réussir dans un de vos improvisation
vous êtes la sagesse ce n'est pas le
voir ce qu'on aime aider mais ce qu'on a
je crois que c'est pas moi c'est ça mais
là il ya des choses que ces décollages
aussi de choses qui vous revient des
choses qu'on a entendues et qui me
touchaient des aphorismes comme ça qui
me mais bon ça c'est peut-être un peu un
peu c'est peut-être une chose de neuf
enfants du catéchisme ne s'est pas des
choses d'une faute est des choses comme
ça je sais je suis un espion au service
du clergé catholique
comment vous vous définissez à la ola
non mais moi je m'intéresse pas
tellement à moi tu sais quand on fait
des choses qu'on se définit par ce qu'on
fait c'est à dire quand je fais quelque
chose je me définis comme ça si je si je
réalise un film j'essaie d'être
réalisateur si je joue je suis acteur
mais si nous on est un personnage trop
envahissant ça ça va pas à quoi il
faudrait que ça sonne elle ce qu'on fait
ce soin d eux c'est beau un fil
les objets un livre c'est beau un film
c'est beau un spectacle des instants
j'essaie d'être ici maintenant des dans
le jeu je regarde vos yeux et aux yeux
bleus et je souhaiterais une petite
déception
non pas du tout dante lumière dans la
nuit vous le faites en direct ce
dimanche
mais si les manières reçoit vous reçoit
le film sera présenté ce dimanche
à l'impérial je pense que vous y serez
ce dimanche oui oui je suis là
beckenbauer
avec le noir et dimanche émaillant débat
il ya un débat après le film avec le
réalisateur
il y aura un débat avec uniqlo et mardi
le suspendant les élections américaines
à l'impérial également eh bien je
choisirais ça plutôt que les élections
américaines
version moderne du terme alors il le 16
novembre ça prend l'affiché au québec
bonne chance pour les oscars aussi et
d'autres césar et des prix des
composants
beaucoup de bercy voilà je remercie
d'aimer venir ici